Just legit,
I don't sit on wallet so I don't play
with wallets.
Fuck no,
sorry.
You're ready.
Oh,
that wasn't sure.
You got up to move cameras around.
Phil.
Show me is you have a mini fanny pack.
It's very small.
It's like you can carry everything I
need and a small phone.
He can't carry a modern phone.
That's like pre modern.
The six fits in there is six plus would
be a problem.
Maybe Bang against your deck.
Tighten up.
So what's going on man?
So for everybody who hasn't seen you on
the podcast before,
let's give them a brief synopsis.
You were a trainer one time at Marine
Land and you,
uh,
you're known as the walrus whisper.
That's your,
your handle on twitter,
which I didn't select by the way.
He didn't know.
How'd you get it?
I was on a TV show called white boat and
it was grassroots as hell in Canada.
So basically what they do is they fly to
Argentina,
they,
they sort of rent the course.
So.
And then they,
instead of it being,
you know,
wipe out whatever country.
This time it's Canada.
So it was really grassroots and so they
told us if you guys can like help
advertise,
so get onto your twitters,
get on your this,
get on your that.
They called me walrus whisper.
It just made sense to put it.
Otherwise I don't particularly love it.
So it was like for a show,
it was great,
but let's explain.
You worked for marine land,
you got fired.
You were,
you were taking care of this wall.
Risks and it,
it became like a big cars because a lot
of people were concerned about the
animal's safety there and since then
they've been cited like what?
What has happened with Greenland?
Okay,
well,
so I'll give you a quick rundown.
So I worked at marine land.
I was killer whale trainer.
I was the guy jumping off the killer
whales doing the flips off dolphins,
everything else.
Um,
I wasn't fired.
I quit amidst some duress,
a difficult period where,
and I'll elaborate the basically a water
disinfection unit broke down and the
resolve wasn't so much to fix it.
It was to pump it with more and more
chlorine basically.
Uh,
the way water is disinfected of
Greenland,
they used an ozone generator,
so they use ozone in conjunction with
the Koreans or mitigate the chlorine use
they elected instead or rather the soul
controlling mind elected to put off
actually fixing it and let's just at
night they're pumping it with chlorine.
Well you can just imagine the effect,
and I'm not going to talk about a little
bit of chlorine.
So this was,
this was a tough time.
So.
So I actually quit.
I actually quit.
I imagine the effect.
So it hurt the animals.
Oh,
we talked about this on the earlier
shows that people want to go back in
time a few years to when you first
appeared on the show,
there was like some serious issues,
health issues with dolphins,
right?
Their skin's peeling off there.
They've got ulcers.
I mean the sea lions are losing for in
patches bleeding out.
I mean this case cases,
at least one animal died and things
started getting real bad.
And of course my walrus in,
in all of this is there and she's in the
water as well.
So if this only compounds the issue,
and the thing about the Walrus is it's
an,
I use the word a lot.
It's anomalous.
My relationship with,
she thinks I'm her mom.
It was like a scientific thing that
happened or brain circuitry opens.
I imprint on her.
So my smell,
everything I looked like or you know,
because when she was a baby,
well she was actually two years old when
it happened.
That's what makes it kind of us on a
baby.
That's not a baby.
No.
How old is that in the wall?
Where swirled like is it dog ears?
No,
she's still young.
I mean dog years.
She's babyish.
Yeah.
Two years.
This is not,
but she's fairly young.
And you were a caretaker so she
imprinted that you were her parents?
Well,
there was sort of a traumatic thing that
happened.
We,
uh,
we were drawing blood from them because
back then,
you know,
they're not trained to,
to,
to accept the pain of drawing blood.
And so,
uh,
she wasn't conditioned for this.
They were young.
We had to get blood.
So we were actually doing a job on
another wall.
Risks and she was sort of loose running
out and we were wrestling her down and
smooshy come over and she's climbing
hectic and crazy and uh,
you know,
she's still almost 300 pounds at that
point.
You know,
you gotta move her if she's,
if she's climbing all over you,
it's a big obstruction.
So I sort of put my hands in front of
her face and that's when it happened.
I'm telling you,
you see it was like a magical moment.
All of a sudden something happened and
she just looked at me.
Her eyes changed.
I changed.
I was now a different person.
I'm not her mom.
She was following me.
So I walked down away from the scene
just following me.
And from that moment on she never
stopped.
And that's just sort of became the basis
of our relationship is that I've sort of
raised her.
So do you put like the touch on her to
touch on it yet with these two hands
right here,
right in front of her face.
And what it.
Is that a normal thing with animals?
Like I said it,
it almost never happens.
You hear if the animal's imprinting on
humans a lot of times,
not usually at her age.
That was a bit advanced for that to
happen.
Usually it happens when they're very
young.
Right.
If it's going to happen.
Yeah,
it does.
It does happen when people raise bears
and a lot of weird animals that you
wouldn't ordinarily think is pets,
but I don't know if it would be an
actual imprint.
Like the imprint is different.
There's one thing of familiarizing.
How do you differentiate?
Well,
it's just.
It's natural.
Oh,
she's protective of me.
She will not leave my side.
I mean I could walk to the edge of the
earth with her and she'll be beside me.
You can't do that with her.
She's still a marine land right now.
I,
yes.
I haven't seen any updated photos and
some,
so I can't be absolutely sure,
but yeah,
I'm fairly sure,
but she's hitting.
They won't do not bring her on display.
Not on display.
You're not gonna.
Find her why they hide.
They hide.
The pinnipeds basically seals sea lions
in the walruses.
They bring them.
In her case,
she doesn't perform anymore.
When she comes out,
she's not reliable,
you can't get to do anything.
All she does is goes out on stage and
she looks for me frantically so it's not
reliable.
So they bring her up between shows
occasionally so she can see the sun and
that's it.
And so,
you know,
I've got to have people in there with
video cameras ready and I mean it's
tough,
but we get the videos,
we get the information I need.
So what's going on with you and them
now?
Because there's been a series of
lawsuits and this is one of the reasons
why you wanted to come in here and talk.
Right?
So they've,
uh,
so they sued me,
of course,
a frivolously they sued me with plotting
to steal a walrus.
Is the,
is the allegation.
This was in 2000.
This is actually a five year
anniversary.
Comes up on a unbalanced plotting to
steal a walrus.
Did you try to get her out of there?
Know if I tried to get her out of there
and have her today?
No,
I wouldn't.
I have nowhere to put a walrus.
Well that's not true.
I do have a river in the front yard,
but I have no interest in,
in releasing her into the Nag River and
then watch her go over the falls.
It's,
I have no interest in that.
So no,
nothing like that.
I don't have a beach front Arctic home
to carrier too.
But yeah.
So they started suing the shit out of
anyone who spoke,
anyone who spoke on the record was
getting sued.
So it wasn't just me,
it was a number of people and uh,
yeah.
So we just elected to try to fight as
long as we could try to sustain this
legal battle because you know,
in lawsuits you've got to reveal a lot
of information,
a lawsuit.
It's not fun like this Greenland's had
everything from my phone to like the,
I mean,
not physically,
but I've given what you mean by
everything.
Like your phone communications.
I have everything.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
So if they sue you for trying to take a
Walrus,
he didn't actually try to take.
They can get access to your phone
records.
They can ruin your life.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean anything they can
get access to your phone or why would
they have access to your phone records
they have?
They have.
I have a legal obligation of giving them
anything that is relevant to their
claim.
So be it communications,
be it photographs,
but what does that mean?
Does that mean they can read all your
text messages,
read all your emails,
read them all?
Yeah,
they know everything.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's crazy.
And I have zero from them after five
years because they're using the system
as a means to just simply abused me and
acting the fool as there as Greenland's
legal team does exceptionally well
proved,
proved very effective in,
you know,
abusing a guy like me.
Whereas a corporation with endless
amounts of money just sue the shit out
of me.
So they're basically just suing you to
punish you and to try to keep other
people from doing the same thing and
talking about them.
They've sued media.
They've sued a student.
Eighteen year old kid from California
who didn't eat.
It was a yet to be released.
A project movie.
He made almost like a cartoon.
He was in the,
uh,
in the key of marine lands,
Canada's last remaining Orca Kiska and a
marine land caught wind of that and they
sued them for a million bucks.
Of course.
I assume that settled now.
I don't know that there's no way of
knowing because I haven't heard anything
of it.
But what was their lawsuit based on?
They,
at least in what I think I just scanned
the documents,
but they alleged that I can't remember
the.
How does that work when they sue someone
from California and does he have to go
to Canada?
That's interesting.
I don't know.
Actually I,
and that's,
that's what was so confusing about it.
I was like,
now you're,
you're suing Americans and stuff like,
I don't know if that works.
They sued another writer in fact as well
in an American writer.
I'm a,
they don't give a shit.
Let's see.
You didn't,
they get,
they get fined recently.
So didn't something happened along those
lines?
Yeah.
They got charged with 11 counts of
animal cruelty a little over a year ago.
Um,
I was in court,
of course marine land,
Sue's OSTP PCA for 21 million,
alleges agency wanted to destroy the
theme park.
So that's where we're going.
So basically down the road,
over the course of,
okay,
I got to get into this.
So the charges,
they have 11 charges of animal cruelty.
First they were five at our five or six
and then an additional five or six.
Now there's a total of 11 charges for
animal cruelty that marina has to go to
the criminal court to defend against.
They drag it on.
As always,
I'm in court every freaking day.
You can bet your ass.
I'm even,
even one time there was a,
uh,
it was a confidential meeting.
In fact it was not for me and a local
writer knock on the door,
cut,
sort of walk in and the lawyers are
looking at us like,
the fuck you doing here,
but we're like,
hey,
like can we sit in on.
But anyways,
so I don't know what you just said.
It was,
it was during the negotiations between
the,
the crown and the Spca for the town.
Yeah,
the crown.
That's the one who would be laying the
charges,
the,
uh,
the animal cruelty charges.
So you get charged.
Okay.
What is the crown?
The crown is the,
is the justice.
He's like the,
essentially the judge.
You're before the judge.
Oh,
sorry.
We don't know what the fuck that shit is
to get confused.
He doesn't wear one,
but.
Okay.
So,
so it's like crown land.
I know crown land.
That's public land.
Yeah.
So,
so I imagine that's probably is in some
capacity.
Why it's called crown.
I don't know.
I'm not,
I'm not a legal expert,
but nonetheless.
So they're in their negotiating and
basically the way animal cruelty
charges,
uh,
are our pursuit is they have to meet to
thresholds.
Number one,
you have to have a reasonable chance of
conviction.
Number two,
it has to be in the public's interest to
pursue a series of the first charges
were immediately dropped because,
and this is just driving me crazy for
years that this has been going on and it
continues.
But if I,
for instance,
if I make a complaint to the LSPC and I
provide a photo of an animal,
which of course I did that is clearly
damaged and fucked up,
if they don't physically have evidence
of who it is that's actually harming the
animal,
there's no cruelty.
They can't do anything.
So in that case,
they dropped the charges against marine
land because the evidence didn't
actually point to anyone specifically.
It was just evidence of damage animals.
So they throw a bunch out,
okay.
But then there was a bunch that were
that they did have a good chance at at a
conviction,
and this is where marine land promised
the crown that this was going to be a
very expensive process,
long and drawn out process,
and the crown agreed that it didn't meet
the threshold.
It exceed the threshold of being in the
public public interest in spending a lot
of of of public dollars pursuing these
charges.
And so they drop the rest of them.
Marine land turns around and Sues Dos pc
for $21,
million claiming that it was malicious
prosecution that of course they name,
they didn't name me specifically,
but I'm always the unnamed Marineland
employee in that and they alleged that I
threatened to defund them and all the,
they think I'm this keyser soze a lead
character,
which I don't mind playing up a little
bit,
but they think I'm pulling strings all
over the place and then I have exists
half don't.
I think there's employees there that
think that I'm like,
I don't know.
So they,
they get brought up on 11 charges of
animal cruelty.
The charges get dropped and they turn
around and sue the government.
Twenty $1,000,000.
The same government that led them off
for years.
The SPCA has been complacent and
complicit in,
in certainly allowing greenland to
operate as they have unimpeded for,
you know,
50,
50 years.
They've had a good relation.
Greenland in fact donated the land of
which the,
uh,
Niagara Falls humane society is,
is built on,
which is where the.
Oh,
SPCA operates out of.
There was a plaque on the wall until,
you know,
after 2012 and we started,
spoke out that honored murraylands owner
John Holder for his generosity.
Yeah.
You sort of get red pill,
is that red pills at the right pill
pretty quickly when you wake up?
Pill.
So that was my wait,
what moment?
Holy Fuck.
Thinks things started to change pretty
fast for me once I realized the depth of
which marine land was sort of in with
all levels of government,
really all levels of government.
And so they,
you know,
they continued to sort of allow for them
to do these things,
but,
but they're suing the government can't
possibly be in bed with the government
and suing them or the Canadian
Association of Zoos and aquarium,
which used to accredit all the zoos and
Canada or still does.
They accredit them.
So they try to,
they try to say,
oh,
this is a good zoo.
It's accredited.
A Marine land,
I believe also threatened them because
they were not going to renew their,
uh,
their uh,
their agreement this year.
And so marine land claimed to have left
them and they said,
you know,
we're,
we're in the phase of development right
now.
We're gonna.
Just leave this Canadian Association of
Zoos and aquariums.
It's absolute bullshit.
They were not.
They were.
So yeah,
marine lines basically has there.
They're out of friends,
that's for sure.
Finally.
But it took a lot of shit to get finally
get that,
to get to that.
But the real issue in your mind is the
way they treat the animals,
the way they run their business,
right?
Is that.
I would say that I've expanded now into
just arguing that those animals should
not be in a relaxed position,
be altogether the whales pools is done,
it should be done,
done.
It should be done.
And I think after blackfish mean before
you came on or when you came on,
it was before black fish had been
released.
And then once people saw what actually
happens to these super intelligent
animals,
when you lock them up in swimming pools,
they,
they're starting to realize it and see
worlds.
Attendance is down and people are down
on the whole idea.
Especially killer whales.
I mean,
God,
they're just giant,
majestic animals.
It seems so fucked up to put them in
these tanks and to separate them from
families.
I mean the emotional distress they go
through it.
I'm a firm believer that emotionally we
don't even have the slightest sense of
how complex they can be because they
don't have an ability to express
themselves to us and other than eating
us occasionally and then weed killer
whales only do in captivity.
Yeah.
There's no.
There's no records of a killer whale
attacks in the wild state.
Fuck people up in captivity though
enough.
Oh,
I've been in the pool with a pissed off
killer whale.
Have you?
Oh yeah.
I jumped in one time.
I was.
I'm a stubborn,
a bit of a cowboy.
He's a young guy too,
and like adrenaline junkie.
I like to have fun.
I like to jump off the kilo,
Elekta her to throw me up high.
So I was having a show with her
basically the way that shows where she
throw you their tail on the end of a
roster mentally.
I never know dunks you.
It's called the rocket ride.
You get on the front of the whale as
such at the top of the water and then
she starts to pump her tail and you dive
down with her.
She'll follow you everywhere,
everywhere you go.
And then,
uh,
it's like flying a plane,
man,
it's amazing.
And then you just arch up and then she
just takes it to the moon and she's
screaming under water when she's having
a good time or rather when she's
expressing herself that she's gonna toss
you this particular time when,
uh,
when I was,
when I probably shouldn't have gone in
the water by while she was pissed,
I could see in their eyes,
how could you tell that she's no,
the animals lick it.
I mean,
that's the whole basis of being a
trainers to get to know the animals,
know their behavior,
know everything about them.
You spend a lot of time with them.
What are the indications?
So in this case I was.
So the way the shows were,
I mean they don't,
they don't exist anymore,
but back in the day was you work the
animal initially just to get a sense of,
of their demeanor.
So you've got to jump in,
you got to run around,
you get a gauge,
you know,
you got a good sense of how they are on
that particular day.
She just wasn't responding real quick.
Her eyes were a little big,
big.
She wasn't focused on Asia.
Looking elsewhere,
she's sort of drifting off a bit.
I just didn't really have her attention,
but I think I don't know what maybe I
had my dad in the crowd or something.
I want it to jump off.
So I look at the senior trainer at the
time,
she's like,
I don't know dude,
like you're gonna jump in and like,
fuck it.
I'm jumping in.
I go to jump in,
I get to the edge of the pool.
She standard directly above or below me.
I dive over her.
She,
she lunges at me and she snaps and I see
it from below me.
Like I see under that.
She's drawn up and snapped at me.
So now I've snapped at you like tried to
bite.
She tried to grab me.
So now I feel like if she really wanted
a bite you,
she would just be like,
oh yeah,
well,
so,
so now I'm supposed to have warning bite
or was it a bite bite?
Prob.
Definitely a warning.
But otherwise I wouldn't be here
tonight.
She if you.
That's what I'm saying.
Like it's not as she would miss.
No,
she's not going to miss so and so and
so.
It gets further.
So now I'm in the water and I'm now at
the top of the water and,
and staring down at her.
She's now inverted upside down and she's
swimming and she's circling the pool.
So upside down.
Yeah.
Huh?
What'd you get frustrated?
They start doing these things.
She's upside down and she's swimming in
circles and I'm looking at going,
Holy Shit,
if I,
if I take off out of the pool,
that's going to trigger some response
out of her that I don't necessarily want
to know.
So I'm saying why would that happen?
I think that it,
if she doesn't want you out of the pool,
you're not getting out.
You're,
if you're getting out of the pool,
it's gonna be.
It's gonna be a hard decision if I,
if I start trying to erase out,
she knows I'm trying to get out.
She doesn't want me to actually stay in
me.
Actually just keep me in it.
I don't want to know where that's going.
That's interesting.
So you knew that you had to stay in
there then?
I'm without choice.
That's,
that's the best course of action at this
point because I'm not going to win a
race out of that pool.
And so now I'm upright.
She comes to the surface and I see her
dorsal fin and she's coming pretty
quickly at me and I put my hands up like
this.
I'll never forget it.
She works her tail down.
Arcserve backup like stops dead at me.
It's,
I remember this big wake happen.
I put my hands on her rostrum I just
sorta tap kind of and then I put my feet
on her pecs.
I sorta,
she takes me to the stage,
she dunks down,
she and then she picks me up,
puts me on the stage.
I sort of back away like,
wow,
thank you.
Thank you for like being nice to me.
I had a friend's dad one time there and
uh,
he's one of these guys.
I told them I took them on a tour.
I'm like,
okay,
just don't touch the big male sea lions.
I mean,
they got big teeth.
They wanna rip your arm off the Kent.
They're not typically aggressive,
but just don't touch him.
And he's in there like this.
I'm like,
Oh dude,
I take them out to show the killer
whale.
I could see that this was another time
of course,
but I could see that she's losing
patients.
And she did the same thing.
As soon as we turned our backs,
I said to him,
I go,
you know what?
Maybe we should just step away.
As soon as he turned his back to go,
she lunged same thing and tried to,
tried to grab.
It's crazy man.
And that was just like,
holy shit man.
So they don't have killer whale shows
there anymore.
Well,
that killed that particular killer
whale.
Kisco.
She's the only one left in Canada.
There's no more in Canada.
There's not ever going to be in
redlands.
Never going to get another one.
Uh,
she's been sort of unresponsive for a
long time.
She's on a lot of medication,
medication,
tons of medication.
What kind of medication do you put a
killer whale on while she's got
different?
Gauge the blood and you start putting
them on an antibiotic antibiotic,
you'd get them on a uh,
uh,
how do you take blood from a killer?
We'll flip over and they got out,
they've got a in their tail,
there's a series of large veins.
You just roll them over and they let you
know everything's.
Everything is.
Everything is trained in that day.
You're going to provide it voluntarily.
So,
and it takes a long time to train these
things,
but you train them to and you just pick
it.
You just literally grab this little
needle.
You put it in the,
in the vein,
and they don't get pissed at you.
They get pissed.
If you miss and you keep trying,
don't do that.
Fuck yeah,
I've seen it.
It happens.
But they let you take their blood if
they're healthy and responsive.
You,
of course,
if they're not,
there's nothing that's going to get you
to the,
get them to the edge of the pool,
but so you,
you take their blood and then they,
what do they find?
Send it to the lab.
You want to look at cortisol levels,
how the stress is you want to look at
white blood count,
see if they're finding any infections.
Uh,
you know,
there's always a,
in her case there's always something,
a lot of the animals are in fact on
value and a lot of different sites.
Yeah.
Tons.
What's that?
That is like rampant use in,
uh,
in,
in the aquariums.
Why?
Yeah.
Volume.
I'm relaying accused me of stealing
value and in fact in the lawsuit as
well,
which is absolutely not true.
Is this,
is this used everywhere or is it
greenland?
Greenland.
Sea World's everywhere.
Yeah.
Yes,
absolutely.
Like dolphins,
dolphins around them all the time.
Sure.
When I was,
when I was,
when I left marine land,
I had the agreement again.
I left fairly amicably considering the
situation,
but you know,
I want it to play my cards right.
And murraylands owner called me back in
specifically to help a dolphin.
And it was the theater.
Of course,
the waste that was in the daily mail.
What's.
What's the other one?
The Dodo.
A good one.
Buzzfeed.
Let's go with buzzfeed.
Seaworld puts its whales unveiling
volume like drug documents say Jesus.
Fuck.
Those documents are from a lawsuit
between marine land and sea world where
seaworld sued Marineland.
See on terrorism at seaworld sued
marine.
Yeah.
The old Benzodiazepines,
I'm telling you.
Wow.
Trainers give their Orkos on the Austin
was killer,
killer whales.
The psychoactive jug.
Benzodiazepine according to the sworn
affidavit filed in order to Ontario
Superior Court of Justice in dispute
between the park company to rival
company marine land over the transport
of a prize.
Killer whale.
I cake a cake.
Cake is if you watched blackfish,
you've got tillikum.
That's the one that killed people.
That's telecom son.
We had his son.
Wow.
We had him.
He was in captivity in captivity in a
pool by himself.
The raised and bred and born in
captivity it,
which is even more fucked up.
And he was turning aggressive and
seaworld was like,
they were having none of it.
They wanted that killer whale back.
And I don't blame him.
It's amazing.
I'm sued for millions because I'm
alleging that,
uh,
that marine land is mistreating their
animals,
sea world,
sue's marine land because they're
mistreating their not taking appropriate
care of the killer whale and actually
win the lawsuit.
They would not put any barriers around
the pool.
We've got a date or green.
I had a large pool.
Imagine this unimpeded.
Ability to touch a killer whale if you
want it to reach.
It's not a safe idea.
This is absurd.
In fact,
especially when you're dealing with a
large,
boisterous male Orca.
So seaworld wanted barriers around it so
that people can't get close.
Well,
the owner Marineland you can't tell him
what to do.
He's not going to do nothing.
Anyone tells them what to do.
So suddenly we're dealing with the fact
that this animal started to lunge at the
public.
Now this is an animal that if it gets a
hold of someone,
it's over.
There's going to toy with them for a
bit.
We're gonna hear a lot of screaming,
but the screaming will end.
You're not getting anyone out of out of
that killer whales math,
forget it,
and this is what [inaudible] was dealing
with.
They're just like,
Shit.
They had enough bad press.
Even back then,
if I kick a kill someone or hurt someone
or anything or dies in Murraylands care,
it's gonna look bad on c one.
So see what it's like getting the fuck
out now.
When tillikum killed people get killed,
how many people?
One person is granted a three to four
actually in Victoria,
Canada,
the first one.
Then he went to a.
I think it's absolutely hilarious and
they kept training them and doing things
with them.
That was a big deal.
That was a pit bull.
Forget about it.
It'd be done,
but it's a killer whale.
Almost any animal lion.
They were training,
you know,
lions and the lion killed someone.
They'd be like,
that's a wrap.
Unless that.
And that's not true.
One grizzly bear that was a train
grizzly bear for films.
It was in,
what's that movie something 40 some
football movie with a big bear.
Anyway,
uh,
the bear killed the guy's brother or
cousin.
I was just standing there.
It's a horrible video.
You could watch the video.
I've seen it.
The guy just standing there and the bear
just decides to tear the guy's throat
apart,
just reaches up,
bites him,
rips his throat open.
The guy runs off,
grabbed his neck.
He's dead within minutes.
The joys of working with animals,
man.
I mean they are.
They kept alive and they started
training him again and there's some
really weird footage of the guard
training.
The Berrigan was the one from the
welfare movie.
But semi-pro.
Yes.
Semi-Pro.
That's the dog or the dog.
Does the bear that bear fucking killed
somebody.
Look,
this guy is smack in this bare ground.
Look at will that bear eventually killed
somebody just got tired of people.
It takes nothing for them.
Oh,
so easy for him?
Yeah.
Just decided to fuck them up.
But now when telecom was doing all this,
he was on valium.
Oh,
I can't say for sure that that was the
case in my suit anymore.
When did they start putting killer
whales on volume?
Um,
so in,
in ocean oceanarium zoos or aquariums
and Shit,
volume is often used as an appetite
stimulant,
so when your animal is off off so they
don't,
they don't eat.
If they're not responding to buckets of
food,
you're fucked.
You having to drop the water to get
access to it because they're not
interested in them or they're not your
friends anymore.
If you don't have a bucket of food,
forget about it.
And so to sort of off enough to sort of
trigger that appetite,
you'll pump them with the value,
give them value,
and if they don't want to eat stuff that
written the phone,
you'd get liquid volume you can inject
as well.
Well if necessary.
Oh,
the injections.
I mean that's a process.
The things that I've seen and done that,
that were normal to me,
normal.
Anyone who's working there is insane.
I mean we used to,
we used to drop,
we used to call this Beluga Rodeo and
emory inland marina is notorious for
having like we have,
I say we a over 50 that puts their
pushing 60 balugas at this point.
And this is why it's so important to
start changing these fucking laws
because this is absurd.
And,
and it creates a whole world of
problems.
Of course,
socially for these animals,
a babies get killed by males.
It's,
it's.
Yeah,
it's gross.
It's bad.
It's not manageable.
Nonetheless,
what we would do is we would drop the
water in one of the pool.
So you'd have anywhere between 10 and 15
balugas flat on their stomach.
There's a great at the bottom and they
can't move.
They can't move well if they want to
move,
they can,
but they're flopping around.
But it means they're going to get fucked
up.
Bad,
like scratched up by the ground.
So if you've got maybe a little bit of
water,
we,
we've tried different things to try to
mitigate how damaged up they got.
There was one time,
I mean,
they get carved up.
We used to call it,
I mean it's morbid,
but we used to joke around,
we called the Cesar water because it was
blood red by the time we were done
procedures.
I'm telling you,
Joe,
it would make you sick.
It was the water was thick of blood and
so one time there was a,
it was a Beluga name peanut and she
started to panic and what she did was
she repeatedly slander tail in a panic.
She started to bounce around like a
fucking basketball.
She was getting air three feet in the
air.
She was,
she's probably a 3000 pound a whale,
2000 pound whale or something.
So you're not going to stop that.
We tried.
Of course,
we jumped on her chunks of her tail.
I'm not joking.
Chunks of her tail flying off,
fly off.
If anyone goes to marine land,
go ask about peanut,
go take a look at her at her tail.
There's nothing left of it.
She's got like a nub that's sort of like
with Jag it on the bottom.
She was fucked up after that.
Again,
lots of meds,
lots of recovery,
but it was foul man.
So is this,
this Benzodiazepine,
is this a recent thing that they started
doing to?
No,
I wouldn't say so.
I can't vouch for anytime before 2000
when I started,
but for sure once we were there,
and I mean when you go to seaworld and
you see those killer whales and dolphins
doing shows,
there just pilled up out of their
fucking minds.
It's A.
It's hardly assemble.
It's merely assemblance of their wild
counterparts.
You're not going there and seeing a
dynamic animal in the more you're seeing
a depressed,
drugged,
confused,
probably frustrated animal and I mean
again,
what those,
what those animals go through it.
It's difficult for people to give a shit
about anything if it doesn't affect them
personally.
If you see an animal going through this,
it,
you feel it.
You start to appreciate it.
Like I feel weird even calling them
animals.
I feel like I'm like killer whales and
dolphins in particular,
so fucking intelligent.
It's,
it's hard to call them animals.
I mean obviously humans are animals as
well,
but they are their own thing.
I mean those marine mammals are their
own thing.
They have their own world and they
dominated it.
Yeah,
and in their world,
man,
it's a fucking amazing world.
This they.
They're one of the only animals that we
know of that has a really complex
language and we can't even decipher it.
And then just last week,
a marine land and Francis is talking
about Wiki is a killer whale that just
picked up a.
She mimics,
she mimics human voice.
So they've got her saying like,
hello,
hi.
And these different things.
And it sort of sounds like she's
mimicking.
What if she started saying a bunch of
racial shit,
racial slurs.
Well then let's get her candidate a band
capture of dolphins today.
Yeah.
But the capture is a,
it's already illegal in the United
States,
right?
Well,
you,
you have to go through the,
you can get them from Canada and Canada
gets them from being captured under that
can get them from anywhere.
This.
So basically the department of fisheries
and oceans very strategically talked
about this sweeping overhaul of the,
uh,
of uh,
whatever this their thing,
whatever it is,
or the words alluding me.
But um,
they did this,
I believe anyways,
sort of mitigate sort of.
Justin Trudeau went off about the kinder
Morgan pipeline sort of.
He ran.
It's that,
it's,
it's a big pipeline that they're going
to run this oil in BC and there's a lot
of protests,
what he ran on the campaign that he
wouldn't do this,
you know,
Justin Trudeau talks about saving the
world level time and cleaning up the
environment.
So they've made this announcement.
Now that's a good,
that's a good piece of legislation.
Uh,
it doesn't bend the breeding,
it doesn't address a lot of the things
that we're actually addressing with Bill
[inaudible],
which is the one that I spoke to you two
years ago,
that marine land has managed to get this
guy,
this senator to keep playing again,
acting the fool,
doing all these creative ways to kill
this bill.
And,
uh,
that's where we're at now.
I mean,
I expect sometime next week to get an
announcement that this bill should have
been passed and brought into the house a
long time ago.
And uh,
you know,
not the case still still stalled at
everything.
And again,
it's all lobbying illegal lobbying,
which may or may not turn into some
problems for Senator Don Plett.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but for while some of the,
some
of the parks in the United States would
get them from some of the parks in
Canada,
which would get them from Russians and
Chinese who would capture them in the
wild.
Right?
So,
so the parks,
the United States would say that they
don't capture whales.
So what they would do is marina would
capture a boatload of wild ones.
And then once,
uh,
they would do it personally while they
would pay some Russians to,
to capture the Russians that they always
use.
Goddamn Russians.
Oh Man,
I'm not going to cheat at the Olympics.
They're stealing whales.
So they bring the whales in wild.
Those why those,
those whales have,
for instance,
a calf,
that calf is now deemed a,
a captive born and now it can be shipped
to the states.
And so,
so what marina was doing was just
breeding like crazy and then sending
them to seaworld.
And that's how we got the killer whale
to begin with.
How we got Kaikos big trade with
Balugas.
And,
and so that's,
we're trying to put an end to because
all these loopholes,
you know,
marina really capitalized on this,
but they want a long time lobbying the
government for years.
I mean they've been around for 50 plus
years.
They've had,
they've done all the right moves.
A businessman would do if he wants to
keep an a thriving business without too
many hands sort of keeping him from
doing anything.
It's just so disturbing that we're
willing to just accept this because we
don't know what they're saying.
You know,
we know that they have a really complex
language.
We can't decipher it though because it's
so alien in terms of like the sounds
that they make.
It's not something you put into a box,
but it's not like any other animal,
but you in dolphins and killer whales
and Wales in general,
they,
they make sounds with a range of
complexity that's just unrivaled in
nature outside of humans.
And their auditory system is so complex.
When you put them in a,
we put them in a concrete pool.
Just imagine what I mean.
I put my ears under the water and it's
loud.
The filters or goal and you've got
different sounds.
I mean water being pushed in from this
pipe and the screaming,
screaming louder.
Louder,
louder.
Pop gone.
The audience.
Yeah.
God Damn.
It's A.
I mean,
I look at them almost like they're kind
of.
I mean they're definitely not human,
but they're are kind of people.
They're like a water people.
It's weird if you,
if you put yourself into a mindset of
looking at an animal and and try to
change your perception of them a little
bit rather than,
than sort of disassociating and you look
and you start,
you can actually see that they're like,
they're people,
man.
Like that's,
that's just a different meat suit.
Yeah.
Like when you deal with killer whales
and stuff,
they evolved in a different environment,
but they evolved to be incredibly
social,
highly dynamic populations.
They,
they live in these very intimate groups.
They stay together for life.
A male killer whale will never leave.
It's mother's side over its lifetime.
It'll stay within about a body's length,
its entire life.
Unless the positives beating on it.
Then I'll just stay on the outside of
the pod for awhile.
At least they have that luxury of
escape.
Whereas in captivity,
males get the shit kicked out of their
big puppy dogs.
Big Male orchids,
I mean.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're murderous killing people,
but they're actually big puppy dogs.
They're there.
I've always felt so bad for candy.
We had this big male,
beautiful,
big bull male.
He was just.
He was rocked his existence,
having been pulled from his mother,
and this is really largely explains why
telecom went off.
You ruined their lives.
That's over.
I mean their whole zone diet,
the reason they live member to their
mother,
but fuck man.
It's just,
why do we allow this?
It seems to me like,
like almost a form of slavery.
I mean,
I don't want to diminish the horrors of
human slavery because in human slavery
at least there's no question whatsoever
that that's a human and there's
communication.
Yeah,
so it's.
It's as awful as it gets,
but God damn put the ignorance aside.
The slavery of killer whales is like
really close.
It's really close.
The only way to get them to work
effectively and efficiently is to keep
them hungry.
Oh,
drug them and keep them hungry.
So yeah,
it's brutal.
Now is it still legal?
I mean,
isn't,
isn't seaworld,
aren't they expanding?
Didn't they just make a bigger a pool
for the killer whales?
We gave them a bigger k.
yeah.
So what they've done is they've tried to
repackage the show as we're not doing
the big dynamic show,
but they really still are.
They're like,
we're just showing natural behaviors,
which is bitch want natural behavior.
Let them go fuck up a whale.
Shit.
They put fuck.
They put like a,
like a backdrop of a couple trees.
Assumption,
like a new show.
Hey seaworld.
There's one other crazy shit going on.
I mean in,
in,
in California.
Seaworld now.
See where promised to stop banning a
rather.
They promised to stop breeding the
killer whales,
but these fucking promises don't do not
believe for a moment that they're like
some type of responsible corporate
citizens.
It's gonna.
Hold on to this thing.
It's bullshit.
And so we're an entity.
The business entity,
they're trying to make money and so what
California did was they went out and
abandoned,
so in California you can't breed orkos.
I import export issues,
all that,
but in Florida,
so again,
see real mix,
the promise.
They had an Orca protection act that
they were looking to do exactly.
California,
we're going to put it.
They were going to make it concrete
passed the law that way that we see
worldcat just backpedal on it,
but the road which everyone suspects
they will see,
well there's lobbying like fucking crazy
and just just last week,
successfully defeated the bill again.
They're putting a lot of the world is
trying to defeat a bill though they
successfully defeated multiple times,
including last week that allows them or
the bill,
the bill would keep them from breeding
these animals in captivity,
so fighting against that successfully
fighting.
It's over.
They're doing it in Florida.
While they're pretending in California,
they don't want to breed them.
Well,
no.
In California,
they actually passed the law,
the state of Florida.
It was defeated repeatedly and now fun
last time.
So they're trying.
They're trying to breed animals in
captivity and if they do breed them in
Florida,
they'll be able to ship them to
California to China,
so that's where the demand is right now.
And in fact seaworld was just bought by
a large Chinese corporation.
They just named.
They just named one of the,
one of the guys to the seaworld board.
And so what people.
I mean it's safe to assume that this is
exactly what's happening is zero.
This is
planning their exit strategy and they're
going to start sending their,
their orchestra to China.
Oh Geez.
It's a booming industry right now.
In fact,
kilowatt captivity is like if you can
get in there and it's all coming out of
Russia,
right?
Still.
But.
And so they're still capturing them in
the wild.
Yup.
And in China it's,
it's a,
it's a burgeoning,
a booming industry man.
40 four ocean theme parks in China right
now.
Jesus is building a black crazy.
How many of them are in the United
States?
How many aquariums?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't say for sure.
I was actually surprised to read.
There's like 300 something dolphins in
captivity in the states.
I had an,
I think that was the number I saw.
I didn't realize it was that big.
I had no idea that there was that many
in captivity in the states.
It just seems to be such an archaic
thing that.
And it just,
I can't imagine that the United States
wants to keep doing that.
The fact that seaworld is trying to keep
doing that in Florida and if they've
successfully lobbied to allow them to
keep breeding these animals in
captivity,
but you can't once you have them in
captivity for a long time,
safe seaworld wanted to release them.
They can't really release them.
There's nowhere to release them.
And that's what's being worked on now.
There's a project called the whale
sanctuary project and I,
I suspect there'll be,
uh,
a fairly large announcement soon.
I believe there'll be looking at a
location in the,
in Canada and they're going to build
this thing though there will be a place
for them,
which is a great place to do it because
they do that.
Well.
You go coastal the course.
I mean,
you've got to be in the ocean,
you got a pen off an area,
you've got to.
I mean,
there's lots of things to consider.
You got to make sure there's a lot of
water changes,
so a lot of different things because you
can't keep the animal and something
that's gonna stagnate and either the
minute,
so it's going to be some sort of a cage
and assume a fence of sorts around that.
Maybe like a fjord.
I wouldn't be a fjord if it's in Canada,
but like just imagine jump it.
I imagined that they'll make certain
that that's not going to be the case,
but it a while they can.
I've seen,
I've seen dolphins jump out of the pool.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I got rushed in one morning to a called
them because uh,
because a dolphin jumped out of the
pool.
Holy Shit that,
I mean,
that's a wake up call when you get there
and you see this thing flopping around
and you're like,
Jesus Christ and I didn't do well.
You get the sling together.
First.
Authors,
you know,
we have these different slings and
things that you know to move these
dolphins.
So I was,
I was alone.
This was a dolphin way.
Yeah,
like 500 pounds,
600 pounds.
In this case she was,
she was a decent size female so I went
and grabbed the kid out in the ticket
booth or some shit cause it was too
early in the morning.
I had no staff there.
Russia,
man.
I'm like,
dude,
I got two guys.
I'm like,
we gotta get this dolphin and these
guys.
I mean if you've never done that before,
your jaws on the floor.
I fucking had these two steel poles all
my shoulders.
Dolphin in the sling,
lifting her up.
I swear to you,
man.
My back went backwards like this.
It was the heaviest thing I'd ever
carried,
but we got her back in.
It was crazy.
But yeah,
jumped out of the pool.
It was crazy.
In fact,
there was a time in the summer,
I remember where one of our dolphins was
teetering on the edge.
What you would do is she,
you know,
they're,
they're always spy hop and like this,
looking over the edge of the crowd.
Explain that to people that are just
listening,
just listening.
So imagine there's like a short wall,
something that you know,
they can look over there,
sort of spy hop in there,
spying up to look.
Okay.
One of our dolphins learned that she can
actually jump up on the ledge and
balance.
Now she was on that.
That's like an eight foot drop to the
concrete on the other side of the pool.
She's up there posing.
I'm hearing the crowd.
I'm backstage.
I hear the crowd going crazy.
I'm like,
what is this?
I go there,
she'll have fun doing this.
Holy Shit.
That's the dolphin that jumped up.
So what we did was I said,
we got to take her out of this pool.
We took her out,
put her in the back pool where no one
would see her.
Of course,
and that's the next day she actually
jumped.
So she'd be dead today if we hadn't
moved her.
Then of course all Marineland did was
put up more,
you know,
more obstruction,
things to keep keep me in the pool.
So now when you find her outside of the
pool,
how long had she been outside for?
She was still wet,
so it wasn't so bad,
but one a one dolphin was.
We found her that she,
she,
she got stuck on the stage overnight and
when we got there her skin had become so
dry that it was,
it was starting to crack.
It was kind of fucked up.
She actually has this permanent scar
from her having tried.
Yeah.
And,
and a chunk come out.
Oh,
I don't know what she was probably
thrashed.
Are you talking to her when you find or
do you try to comfort her?
Like,
I mean,
yeah,
sure.
I'm hugging her and everything else.
Let's say she.
Did she calm down when she realizes
people were trying to help her?
Like are they aware of what's going on
or she in a pan?
They always fight.
They always fight if they don't.
I mean this particular dolphin was a
fighter.
Every time we ever tried to put her in a
sling and move on,
I mean,
one time,
I love that I could go back in memories
and I can,
I can remember my thoughts during these
times.
And uh,
we had her in a sling hovering over the
pool and the way the sling is just,
you've got two holes in the ceiling
where the pecs go in,
right?
The pectoral fins and then one where the
genital split is.
So if they shit it doesn't wind up stuck
in the,
in the sling,
but.
And then you've got a crane,
a top.
So now you've got this thing lifted over
the pool.
Well,
she's fighting like crazy and we can see
that there's a tear in the sling as
she's fighting,
fighting,
fighting.
We get her.
The crane just gets rid of the pool,
the sling rich,
he's plunked into the pool.
Holy Shit Man.
And we've,
we've slimmed out like 15,000
pounds,
10,000
pounds killer whales over like 30,
40 feet in the air.
Imagine one of those drops.
Oh my God.
So that was sort of a wakeup call.
Wow.
Yeah.
Archaic Procedures,
man,
moving these,
these things,
the things that,
especially at a place like marine land
marina,
when you step through the doors and
hopefully you don't,
but if you do,
it's like you've gone back to the
seventies.
Has any of this hurt their business?
Attendance is a bismal over there.
They're crushed.
I live right.
I.
I watched the sunset over marine land
from my front yard.
It's a beautiful site.
I drive by of course,
just about every day that their
attendance is rocked and Nag or falls,
which were.
Which is where murray lender is,
is booming.
The tourism is through the roof.
You can it's shoulder to shoulder over
there and greenland.
Seeing none of it.
And you think it's because people know
about the conditions.
Absolutely.
Oh,
I've got a lot of support in the local
community.
Like people know exactly what's going
on.
A tourist is a little more difficult
than,
you know,
Niagara Falls welcomes millions of them,
so you're going to get a fraction of
that,
but it is a fraction.
Marineland is not benefiting from the
booming tourism there.
They're on their way out.
They're on a clock for sure.
For sure.
I'd be shocked to hear them opening in
2019 if I'm not going to make that
prediction,
but I would be shocked if it's that bad.
But to be fair,
there's no investors that Marineland
it's one soul controlling mine,
owner who started with nothing.
I started with 2000 bucks,
built this thing.
He is indebted to nobody.
He's,
you know,
he's cash Richard Course and he's got a
lot of fucking money and not a lot of
times.
So he's out to fuck shit up.
I wouldn't be surprised to know a lot of
time in life.
You mean he's like 84 years old now?
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
I,
I wouldn't be surprised to think that
he's rationalized in his mind to just
fucking sewer this thing like destroy,
destroy all our lives.
We're having spoken out,
but just tank the park in the process.
Fuck it.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's very defined.
He's,
he's a,
he's a very paranoid and defiant men.
And so,
you know,
at 84 years old,
what else does he have left to
accomplish?
I guess so you were saying they had 50
Beluga whales,
the plus,
maybe even 60 at this point.
Beluga whales are huge.
Yeah.
What is a big one way?
I don't know if we've ever met.
If we ever actually weighed our big
metal gas at 4,000
pounds,
maybe five.
You got 50 of those 50 of them.
Yeah.
That's insane.
Try Catching one.
Oh,
I don't want to try.
I used to get tasked with,
here's your.
Here's your scuba gear.
Here's a.
A net the size of a football field.
Good.
Catch that believable.
Well,
me and my buddies would be like,
okay,
here we go.
Oh Dude,
you'd be.
He'd be it.
It really would be amazing to be able to
capture the things we've done on video.
Can you recognize the difference in
intelligence between killing whales,
dolphins,
Beluga whales,
and killer whales are remarkably
similar.
Just cunning.
Smart.
You turn your back and they're
pickpocketing you.
I mean they are just.
And they're brats and I love brats.
I mean they just are bratty animal.
They're having fun.
They're having,
while they're fucking with you,
they would like to make things
difficult.
If they know,
if they know how to frustrate you,
they're going to exercise that.
So it's always a mental game,
especially when you're dealing with
animals.
Treating with that was a Beluga.
Whales are really timid,
so like,
you know,
they call him the canaries of the sea
because it kind of skittish.
So I don't know if that's a reflection
of their intelligence necessarily,
but I would call them like maybe a,
maybe a hint more dumb dumb than then
the next one.
Right.
But you know,
they're more scared shitless of either
not,
you know,
because they don't really want it.
They don't want to be,
they're not as smart as dolphins are.
I wouldn't say so.
I mean it's wrong me in some way,
some way.
Intelligent,
you know,
they're sort of sitting ducks out there.
Blue Goes.
I just mean like in the,
in the,
in the whale world,
the whales respond,
they respond to verbal commands.
Yeah.
So in the case of pinnipeds absolutely.
So seals and walruses a clc lines,
they re,
they respond to verbal a whales.
We,
I,
I couldn't say for sure in my experience
that that was the case.
However,
in the case of just that announcement
last week of that animal mimicking the
human sounds,
it means she hears him.
So if you can hear,
if the animal can hear you,
you can definitely create a queue of
sorts to trigger behavior.
So it's possible that they could know
some of our language.
I don't know that they could recognize
commands.
Yeah.
I wonder.
No,
we,
we know that they have dialects,
right?
But we don't know anything that they're
saying,
right?
No.
Uh,
and that's what's interesting is,
I mean,
I sort of beat myself up wondering if in
fact they're using a language that is to
be interpreted as words,
sentences versus sounds that mean
things.
I guess maybe that's what you're saying,
but I know what you're saying.
It's not something that's necessarily
decipherable you know,
the,
you know what a dog's pissed because
they grow.
A girl is different than a bark barks,
barks out necessarily words.
And if they are,
maybe they're fuck you,
I don't know,
but I was listening to this thing about
monkeys.
Um,
I think it was Steven pinker's book
where they were talking about,
um,
it was the audio book.
They were talking about how monkeys have
differentiated the sound that they make
if there is a tiger versus a sound they
make.
If there's an eagle anytime I'm walking
around and I hear a squirrel in a tree
making a certain sound.
I know there's a cat in a vicinity
that's probably one of them,
but they have a language,
like a very crude language.
But what they've done is taken the sound
of an eagle and they play it near
monkeys.
The monkeys look up,
of course,
and they play the sound of a monkey
trying to alert the fact that there's a
tiger in the area and the monkeys run up
trees and start looking down.
Yeah.
It's really interesting because like
they have a few sounds that they can
repeat and they know for a fact that
these monkeys know what they're talking
about.
And monkeys even played jokes.
That's a language with each other.
They play jokes on each other,
like if one monkey wanted a banana,
he would say,
hey man is a fucking eagle here,
and the monkey would run up the tree and
he would get the banana like they would.
They lie to each other.
Just pretty fascinating.
It makes doing fucked up things to them
that much worse,
right?
You mean monkeys a mean?
We know that they're intelligent,
but they got a little tiny little tiny
brain.
Little tiny has had little tiny brain
know,
but it's all I need orcas,
brain,
those giant.
These are huge,
enormous brains.
Dolphins.
Brains are dolphin.
Brains are way bigger than ours.
You want to hear a fucked up story?
I had to dig up a dead killer whale to
extract a portion of its brain that we'd
missed during a necropsy.
You have to dig it up.
Yeah.
It was ground that was in the ground.
He had been married for like 10 days to.
Whoa.
Oh Dude.
How'd he die?
I can't remember how candy died exactly,
but he did.
He died pretty young.
Um,
I can't remember exactly what the final.
We never got that information as as
trainers,
you sort of.
We're always told,
oh,
it was,
you know,
it's always a meningitis.
It op.
He died of meningitis or,
or they would say,
oh,
twisted and testing or something.
They always came up with things that you
just know.
It kept you asking questions rather than
feeling like anything was ever
conclusive in that regard.
But on this particular case,
or in this particular case,
the vet had pulled me aside and said,
okay,
I gotta ask you something fucked up.
Can you go get two people sued them up.
We got to go get a piece of the brain.
We missed of candy.
I'm just like,
ugh.
I can't possibly impose
upon someone to do that.
I can't.
Deep Deepa had been buried like it's
booked six,
eight feet.
He was,
and you could just do that in the yard.
They allow you to just bury it in the
yard.
Maryellen has mass graves in the back in
the exact place that they're claiming
development now,
which I've got some overhead shots.
They've acted like paving roads pretty
close to it to where the bodies are
buried and what,
like how many different things you think
are buried?
Thousands.
I mean just in deer alone.
Forget about.
I mean,
greenland breeds more deer and why do
they breed dear?
He's got.
He's got a whole park of animals,
different animals.
That's where the,
the animal cruelty charges stemmed from
was actually was not marine mammals
because there's no laws protecting them
so that they continue to live in a void
of protection.
But the,
the,
the deer's,
the bears.
There's no laws in Canada,
in Canada yet.
It's coming,
man.
And I've been talking about this for
five years.
We're almost there,
but I'm up against the fucking wall
first.
Come on here.
Two thousand 13 was my first time here.
Yeah.
So that would have been four years ago.
So they have thousands of graves in the
back.
Thousands of animals in,
in large graves.
So this big hole for instance,
there's a big hole for the deer.
They're all going in there.
The theory or the eat them,
it used to back in Christmas,
uh,
back in the day when he used to,
when the owner used to host Christmas
parties,
he'd go back and slaughter a,
buys it and then feed burgers and make
food out of stuff.
And they used to do that.
They don't do it no more.
They actually used to be called a uh,
uh,
something in game farm.
And then by,
by being a farm classified as a farm,
he was actually able to kill them,
produced food.
So that's something I,
I,
I've been told that happened now.
Why did they kill deer back there?
Why go to a whole?
Well,
I mean,
a lot of them die because their gross.
First off,
when you got 500 deer in a,
in a,
in a pen,
that's like disgusting.
They're not all gonna get to eat.
Some of them are going to get injured.
These things happen.
So at night what would happen is
someone,
let's say we'd drive around in his
truck,
you know,
put the gun out the window and just eat
it.
Just go on the shooting sprees,
wiping out these animals in the morning.
The land animal care guys would show up
and it'd be like,
okay,
go,
go pick up the bodies and these poor
kids.
So what do you do it for a goof or what
do you do it because he's trying to thin
the population because there's too many
of them.
Oh No,
it wouldn't be anything like that.
Well,
in one case,
once the,
once the investigation came out in 2012,
which revealed of course abuse with land
animals as well,
uh,
they went on a calling spree,
if you will,
where they got rid of some of the
uglier,
sort of less healthy animals.
It's funny because.
Yeah,
because marina actually breathes the
more beautiful deer off site.
The more beautiful animals that they
have on are not on display.
They're actually back there breeding off
out of display.
That's where the two dogs,
I don't know if you recall when the
owners shot those two labs,
beautiful little labrador dogs went
running into the,
up and down the running up and down the
fence across from,
you know,
murraylands owner's house.
Which is where the offsite Penn is,
where he breathes the animals and that's
where he decided,
I'm not calling anyone to come get these
analysts do the story.
So heartbreaking.
He just pulled out a shotgun,
kills one.
The other one cowers because there was a
witness.
Of course the witness never identified
themselves.
They didn't want to be sued and then he
shoots the other one and then he tells a
land animal care supervisor takes these
as take the collars off the dogs,
go bury him in the pit.
It was.
I was there that day.
I heard the gunshots.
I was there when the vet got the phone
call and she's like,
oh my God,
okay.
She hangs up.
She looked at me.
He goes,
John just killed two dogs.
I'm like,
what the fuck man?
Dogs that you can go,
hey,
go back home.
Poppy's dude.
They were beautiful dogs.
There was a video.
It's since been taken down on the trump
star website.
A lot of the videos are gone.
A lot of things are happening now on
account of these lawsuits and further
down the road that we've gone where
things are starting to disappear.
There was a,
it was a very powerful historical
website about marine and some of the
owners history and you know,
these things are gone now.
They're gone.
I mean,
I can't allege as to why or what
agreements are.
If there are agreements,
I can't go down that road to suggest,
I don't know,
but a lot of these resources that I,
that were very powerful are,
are gone and disappearing now.
So he's.
This marine land has this giant yard,
right?
How many acres are you talking about
where there's thousands of animals
breed.
I mean,
the park is massive.
It is.
There's more,
there's probably three times undeveloped
land versus what's develop there.
And it's a big park.
It's sort of barren.
There's not a lot of things.
His rides and you got to walk a mile in
between them,
but nonetheless,
uh,
the owner,
what do you like to do?
Was,
was sort of acquire a lot of land over
his lifetime that,
that was his thing.
He owns half an agora fault.
I got to watch what the hell I stepped
because any given point,
if I'm.
If I'm on their land,
I'm getting charged with trespassing,
whether I like it or not.
In fact,
the city of Niagara Falls leased land to
marine land to keep protesters off of
their site,
which is absolute bullshit and if
anyone's listening from city council,
I'm hope you do,
you've got to fix that because that's
some horse shit right there and then
that you guys had been pandering to on
for too long.
I mean to keep us from being able to
protest.
That's horse shit.
Sorry.
Why do you think that is?
Because they just don't want to get
sued.
There was a time when marine land and
owner were called like the king of
Niagara.
That was it.
Marine land was a top.
The hill that was the falls came second
to marine land,
or at least marineland played the,
the.
This idea that people came to Niagara
Falls,
they would see the false.
They'd say they'd look at him for 10
minutes and then they would have no
reason to stay.
They were saying they're bringing all
this business because people are now
going to a hotel,
it's going to restaurants and it's going
to marine land the next day.
And so when did this change?
When did marine land go to shit?
Yeah,
2012.
So right when you left.
So before then it was this thriving
thing and just nobody knew about the
conditions.
That's what it was,
were ignorant of people wouldn't have
known who's going to talk.
It's not new for murraylands owner or
marina and the corporation to sue people
for speaking out.
They did it before and successfully.
Not in the sense that there was any
judgment,
but successfully in that the people that
spoke had to pay a horrible price and
you know,
essentially got silenced.
So no one wants to speak out against
that.
No,
I don't blame them.
I get it.
I mean,
I'm eating it now.
It's been five years,
five years of everyday waking up
wondering if this is the one where
you're done,
you know.
So you've been embroiled in these
lawsuits for five years.
Five years on,
on.
They sued me on Valentine's Day of 2013
yet and nothing's been resolved.
The only way that there could be a
resolve at this point is if I were to
sign a document and I'm,
I'm assuming at this point because
Murraylands sent nothing in terms of any
type of agreement,
but you know down the road it's their
objective is to shut me up.
They want to wipe out the last 20 years
of my life.
They don't want me to open my mouth
about anything in of course,
in the last five years and then the
twelfth prior when I sort of revealed
everything that's going on,
they're trying to shut me up.
They want me.
They want an injunction,
a permanent injunction.
I assume they would.
That to keep me from being able to go to
the park with this becomes very
conflicting for me because they have my
walrus sort of hostage there and I do.
I do dream of a day of being reunited
with her and I imagine that would have
to take place on marine land property
someday.
So it's really not prepared to sign
anything.
In fact,
I told my lawyer just last week,
it's a nonstarter and I'll remind marine
land now nonstarter.
They'll never shut me up.
I'm not signing it.
I'll have to eat shit forever,
but I'm not going to sign it.
So where do you anticipate this all
going?
I mean you've been,
you know,
prolong legal battle for five years now.
Where do you anticipate this going?
And so in April.
So last time I was here two years ago,
I,
you know,
I solicited some,
some,
some help resources to be able to pursue
murraylands owner in that I want him to
be examined in court,
much like I have in the same capacity
that I had to forfeit all of my
communications.
I want the same for the corporation and
I want to examine murraylands owner as
representative.
This proved very difficult.
It took A.
I mean we got the ordered only just last
April to examine him.
We got,
we won the order and since then we've
tried multiple times to schedule and
we're,
we're almost a year now of trying to
schedule this man to come in for
examinations and he's not shown up a
couple times now and so at some point if
marine land doesn't want the facts out
there and that's what I'm pursuing,
I want the facts out there,
they're going to have to,
they're going to have to settle and so
how that ends with me,
I don't know.
I'm not looking for money.
I could give a shit about trying to get
rich in this thing.
Are you trying to sue them for money
though?
I'm suing them.
Yeah,
but it's a much.
Well,
the numbers don't matter,
but that's like a million and a half or
something.
They defame the shit out of me.
Let's be honest.
It's pretty absurd.
But again,
so would the million and a half.
I'd never get it.
I'll never see it.
But would it be a predicated on you
would have to shut your mouth if it
wasn't something that went.
If it wasn't a judgment that the judge
made,
for instance,
we went to trial,
the judge makes their decision.
Then if we settled beforehand,
it's because everyone wants to wash
their hands and walk away.
We're not going to wash their hands of
me unless I feel,
unless I've got them properly cornered.
The only way they want to get me is,
well,
of course they want to ruin me.
Right?
How can you properly corn to them?
What be well,
if murraylands owners missed a couple
examinations now how many until I can go
in and actually file a motion to have
the entire statement of claim dismissed?
Well,
the fact is pretty soon,
so my objective is to go and get this
lawsuit thrown out.
At which point they've only got.
I've got the counterclaim for them to
work with.
They're not suing me no more.
Now who's got the upper hand?
That's my dream.
That's your dream.
But if,
if that doesn't happen,
I mean it seems like five years is a
long time to be in the prolong legal
battle.
Like at what point in time,
but does it become so absorbed that the
court throws it out?
So it just happened.
Now it's actually a new rule that as of
February 2018,
any lawsuit that hasn't been scheduled
for a four trial was administratively
dismissed.
There's a new law and so that doesn't
affect mine unfortunately because we
actually fought to get a case
management,
a judge on our case be on my case
because like I said,
Greenland's acting the fool.
I can't seem to get in front of a judge.
Everything's joke around.
So we went and won that again.
It took a long time.
You know,
what's the crazy thing about these
lawsuits?
And I,
I see now of course in 2012 was a lot
more naive,
but all of the wins that I get in court
cost me.
So for instance,
I,
I defend a motion against marine land.
It costs me $7,500.
The judge says,
okay,
Phil wins this round.
Let's give them some money back on a
partial indemnity.
He gets 3,500
bucks back.
It's not just cost me four grand
murraylands owner Mrs.
Examination as as an example,
I've got to get what's called a
certificate of attendance.
I got to send a lawyer 1200 bucks.
So it's.
And how is all this funded now?
Oh,
I have a public go fund me.
Of course.
I've had several and how do people if
they want to donate,
because I'm sure a lot of people
listening to this like,
fuck this man.
I got to help this guy saved
smooshy.com.
I've got my documentary on there,
which I'd like to touch on a little bit.
It's great if you had a chance to look
at it,
watch.
Oh,
okay.
Well if you get.
If you manage to.
It's.
It's pretty.
It's good.
These kids from Ryerson University did
it.
Brave kids and how I know it's a very
effective law or a documentary is that
marine land didn't sue them.
They know the danger of this
documentary.
They know how powerful it is and they
didn't sue him and that's how I know
that this is powerful and so they
decided that it's so good they have to
leave it alone and just ignore it
because if they sue them then it'll put
attention to.
Exactly.
And so they made a small statement
saying,
Oh,
this is Phil just doing what Phil does.
And it's funny because the Ryerson
students turned out to be.
They go,
but that's not true.
Like we came to you.
They just went.
They actually wanted to do it five
minutes.
A personal profile of me.
They said,
look,
we want to just do a quick interview
with them.
Like sure.
That morning,
I don't know.
They come in the right day.
I just,
you know,
we spoke for hours and then they sort of
got back and said,
know we want to do like maybe something
more with this.
I'm not asking you guys do whatever the
hell you want.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm an open book.
I'd give everything away.
You want something here,
go go nuts with it.
And so they did and they did something
great.
It's really good and uh,
so,
you know,
definitely,
definitely.
Please check that out.
You know,
we'll do it every time I talk to you,
I'm happy to talk to you.
You're a great guy.
But we always get fucking hugely sales
conversations.
I'm always just like,
what?
Fuck.
And now the volume do it.
If I have to get into my own personal
wellbeing.
I mean you get compromised when things
like this happen.
You do,
you just do.
I imagine it's a half a decade of
stress.
It's a lot big portion,
but I'm turning 40 in a month.
So from 35 to 40,
34 all been stress in lawsuit everyday.
And not just that they're sending goons
to my house.
I mean they sent the police to my house.
I mean,
it,
it really is relentless.
It's absurd.
The things that he.
There was a comedian,
I don't want to mention his name because
he deleted the tweet that he.
And he told me,
Oh,
twitter deleted.
It was bullshit.
So I'm not gonna I don't want to give
him any attention,
but Peta had tweeted something and so he
quoted that tweet and said,
it's time to burn.
This place is a comedian.
Very funny.
I click retweet.
I got the police,
uh,
cyber crimes unit on my front door the
next day because the lawyer sent them
because I,
uh,
I,
inciting violence incited violence for
the followers.
So now marina was worried that the
buildings are going to be burned down.
Well,
I would never say to do that mean either
fuck them or I would never tell anyone
to fly a drone over it.
Either opportunity for million view
youtube hits.
Yeah,
don't do it.
Don't do that man.
It's just,
you know,
that they're on the wrong side of
history and not just marine land,
but all of these places,
all these places like there's gonna come
a time in the future where people look
back at this kind of captivity of these
hyper intelligent social animals stolen
from their families.
It's a terrible,
terrible statement about human beings.
The thing I love about,
I guess,
what you would call them a my campaign
is that I have support from hunters.
I have support from vegans.
I am across the spectrum.
At one point I had a far right,
well personally is perceived as a far
rates,
uh,
Internet personality.
Tweet my,
a documentary and then Rosie O'donnell
tweets it and she's left as it gets.
And so I'm looking at.
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Oh Dude.
I got a rosy story.
It's kind of heartbreak or actually,
but when I went to New York,
and again,
Joe,
thank you so much for when you,
when you spoil me with those ufc
tickets,
do that.
It's always the most timely thing and so
appreciate it because it's,
it's,
it's just like this trip,
it's exactly what I need at the time to
start.
Keep myself a little break and have some
fun.
And so I was going in New York City,
know what I'm saying?
Message.
I'm like,
dude,
and you're like,
Bro.
And I'm like,
ah.
And so,
so rosy sees the documentary and someone
says to me,
hey,
rosie just tweeted a documentary.
I'm like,
oh cool,
so I go to her twitter and shit.
So I followed her.
She followed me back just to send me
messages like,
dude,
like it's really powerful.
I really like.
And then she goes to elaborate like,
I want to know more about you,
want to call you tomorrow.
Okay,
cool.
Sure.
As Shit.
The next day the phone rings.
I'm talking to Rosie.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
I'm again,
I'm for.
I know who rosie is.
I don't know if these days.
If kids know who Rosie Rosie O'donnell
was like,
I don't know.
She was a heavy in my daily.
She's left a powerhouse and she's
expressing all these interests.
Like,
you know,
I've,
I've done documentaries,
I've released them on Hbo,
you know,
I've done all these things.
I'm going to,
I'm going to La Tomorrow and I'm gonna
call you back on Friday,
but I'm meeting with this emmy award
producing a producer and we're gonna get
this thing out there.
And then she starts to say,
and this is where my heart starts to
ache,
is that,
you know,
you always sort of hope that there's
going to be a hero that,
I mean,
especially the last five years,
it's gonna be like,
you know what,
enough's enough,
let's,
let's do this.
And especially in the case of with my
Walrus,
she starts saying,
I think we can get the Walrus,
like we can get some pressure,
get a TV network pressure.
So let's get that Walrus.
I'm just like,
dude,
you're pulling on my fucking heart
strings now.
I,
you know.
And then I went to New York,
I'd hope to have lunch with rosie on
that particular trip.
I was going for two reasons,
actually was also was hoping to do some
Iowasca I'm looking to get a reset.
Oh I,
I,
I need some.
I'm going to do that soon.
Sooner than later.
But that was,
that was the intention of going to New
York.
And uh,
and since then it's just been radio
silence from Rosie,
unfortunately.
And I,
I accept that in that she has a
complicated world and whatnot.
But man,
she pulled on my heartstrings,
don't,
might've wanted to do it and couldn't
and I'm not going to fall.
I see how crazy sort of her life and
sort of things that go on in the end.
Totally.
You know,
she's got a lot of family issues and all
sorts of other stuff too.
But yeah,
that's a bummer.
It's just a bummer is what it is.
I think uh,
also people get involved with you and
hear the stories and then they get
scared of being sued themselves all the
time.
Yeah,
you should see it.
I mean,
I just,
even last week I contacted someone that,
uh,
I mean the media now and mind you,
it's a very different landscape now from
2012,
2012.
The media was against me.
Corporate media was in Rhode and had
them in their back pocket.
That was before blackfish.
Two thousand 13,
2014,
7:15
media's mine,
2016,
17,
18.
Now the media is just,
who knows what the fuck they're doing,
man.
Like it's all over the map.
So it's hard to get any sort of.
And again,
Marineland will sue them.
So it's also an issue of after things
had been going on for so long and
nothing's happened,
people start going,
well,
what?
What can I do?
You know,
a lot of people actually think
murraylands done.
They're just like,
oh dude,
congrats.
Murraylands dead,
right?
Like,
no man is still happening.
It's still being sued.
It's all happening.
It's just less current account that it's
five years.
But that's exactly,
they're there.
That's what they're doing.
That's our objective.
But I think also the land fatigue and
people are tired of fucking hearing
about it.
I'm tired of trying it,
you know?
Well it's,
I think also the 11 different counts of
animal abuse.
You know,
they probably fought like,
oh,
this is it.
No,
I thought that that was it.
And then they turn around a pseudo Spca,
which I mean,
man,
it's all dark man.
It's really dark.
And the fact that there's so many people
involved helping,
it feels dark,
you know,
it feels,
feels like total violation of my life.
Like whatever.
I'm,
I'm up for it.
I'm here to fight.
But it feels gross.
You're at every turn being like fucked
and all you can do all I can do and in a
lot of times I'm not really allowed to
even speak of it.
I mean,
I may have even compromised things in
this.
I mean,
I always compromise things when I,
when I speak,
but it's,
that's what's choice.
How do you compromise things here today
by telling true stories?
I'll find out tomorrow or Monday when I
get a whole deluge of fucking legal
threats.
I,
I've been threatened with more lawsuits.
Marine lands lawyers have in fact
threatened other whistleblowers lawyers,
so they're ready to sue lawyers.
I mean,
you want to talk about gumming up a
system that's over at that point.
If a lawyer who's another lawyer,
you're looking at 15,
20 fucking years and wasn't there
changes in the laws in Canada,
like how you can sue people.
There was anti slap legislation that was
enacted years ago.
I spoke at Queens Park is something that
you were.
Yes,
of course,
of course.
And then slap stands for strategic
lawsuit against public participation.
So I speak out against what's happening
at marine land,
Greenland to multicasts rich corporation
sues the shit out of me and strategic
way to try to silence you.
Right?
And so Ontario,
uh,
passed a legislation to make that
illegal.
However,
at the time Ontario's premier was suing
the leader of the opposition.
She took out the retro clause so it was
no longer retroactive to any lawsuits
that are already in the system.
So now I'm actually fighting against a
lawsuit that is illegal.
And if it were to be applied to my
lawsuit,
had it been marina would be up against
some punitive damages like crazy just
for by fault of launching a malicious
because it's.
But because it's not retroactive,
I sit back and,
and I just continue to eat it.
And then other people that actually I
see it in the paper went.
So I was like,
Oh,
this corporation tried to sue this
girls.
They owe her half a million dollars for
a while.
Maybe not have nothing,
but they all are some money for,
for having lost the suit.
And I'm just like,
oh dude,
my dreams God damn man.
I feel for,
you know,
don't man,
you know what to be fair,
it's also,
I call it a sort of a curse and
blessing.
I mean,
look,
I'm here man.
In what world would I be here?
I was started out as a fan of the show.
I started listening to you saying things
like,
be the hero of your fucking move yours,
whatever that quote was.
And I did.
And so I,
I get the idea,
I,
I get I each but shit starts to taste
delicious.
When you see the damage you're doing as
well.
What are you doing for money now?
So I started the business,
a summer business some years ago.
I've got an Airbnb,
which is like was the best idea I've
ever had.
I'm so happy and blessed with this thing
because people come down and I host them
now.
It's the thing I like to do the most.
I got a beautiful home on the water.
It's leaking.
I got nice doc converted where the
apartments into an airbnb in honor of my
cat that we spoke of.
In fact two years ago,
Eugene.
So it's called the Eugene.
And so,
you know,
that's,
that's a means to sort of sort of
helping me.
I go on occasionally.
I worked for a,
for Canada post as a mailman,
which I sort of love in that.
It challenges me everyday.
I wake up in minus 20 degrees,
wind powerlink blowing snow like crazy.
I got to go spend like six to eight
hours walking in this shit.
It sucks.
But that's challenge and you gotta wake
up and rise to it,
right?
I mean,
you could just as well stay in bed all
day,
but that's not gonna help me.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing about mail delivery
in a lot of places.
It's still walking around.
Oh,
I do it.
It's brutal.
But I love it.
I'm walking 20 k a day,
dude.
I lost a lot of weight.
I'm feeling good.
It's how it helps me.
It really does.
I,
I'm a,
I need to.
I need my body moving.
I know one speed fast,
know I'm 40.
I'm slowing a little bit,
but not that much.
Surprisingly.
Uh,
hopefully.
Hopefully my run last for awhile,
but it helps me.
The voice in my head goes from,
dude,
everything's abysmal and fuck to do.
You got this man.
Stick with it.
You got this.
You know,
you listen to music and getting
powerful.
You're feeling good,
man.
It's just right for me.
It really is.
In a perfect world,
where would you look all this to end?
I want the walters.
Sounds crazy.
My dream is I'm going to free whales.
There's going to be a sanctuary.
I'm going to free marine lends whales.
I'm going to have a hand in this.
That's going to happen.
Number two,
really think that's going to happen.
You think they're gonna enact
legislation that makes them release
those animals?
I think so,
yes.
Really?
What makes you so hopeful?
As two or three,
they realized tried to kill this bill
for years.
Now they've not been able to in this
time next week,
so the sucker should go that whale
sanctuary.
Sanctuary project.
They're going to build a whale
sanctuary.
There's going to be a place where
whales,
if it's in Canada and all the
exportation laws are that marine land
can't get rid of their whales.
There will only be one place for whales
if that business elects to evolve or if
there's any type of ownership changes.
I see this being explained to me how
this sanctuary would work.
Well,
you'd have an environment where is a pen
off in the ocean and I mean various
different pens for various different
procedures if you will,
but the idea is that you,
if they can't be wholly released,
then you've got to place where they have
a sense assemblance of,
of,
of freedom,
if you will,
but it'll be an human care.
There'll be more of like,
for instance,
a viewing platform where people will be
able to view the whales versus and how
big of an area we're talking about
massive.
Yeah.
I don't.
I can't say the square footage.
I don't know because that nothing's
finalized so we're still under the
development.
Would they develop a bay or something
where they would want to ideally get a
bay that has good water changeover that
you know that that works.
If you can find that,
and I mean the east coast is looking
really good these days.
Is there a model that they've drawn up?
Not.
Oh,
there's models.
Yeah.
No,
absolutely.
There's.
When we look at something like this,
if you haven't got the whale sanctuary
project,
I'm sure you'll find tons of different
things.
I just don't know how they're keeping
the ORC in those things.
If you put a fence up,
they're not going to go anywhere.
They wouldn't jump the fence.
They don't.
There's something about jumping out.
I mean,
when the.
When the wild captures happen,
what do we got here?
There's the whale sanctuary point
building.
A model sanctuary were kept whales and
dolphins can reread habilitated and live
permanently in their natural
environment,
so it's a step.
So this is a step between this and then
the wild.
Yes.
No.
Are they going to free them and then
release fish in there for them to eat?
I imagine there'll be all of that.
Every which way.
That would be nice to the.
Allow them to actually hunt and kill the
fish,
which I'm sure that's what they want to
do.
The fact that they can feel the natural
rhythms of the sea.
I mean,
they're in tune with the senior in their
environment that the pools.
No,
please look what it says here.
For medium survive,
for years,
median survival time in years for wild
caught orcas at a marine park for years.
One thousand 100 square yards of space
and a large display tank.
And a typical high end marine tank.
Three hundred 14,600
is the minimum number of square yards
for the first whale sanctuary project.
Seaside sanctuary.
So this is 314,000,
600 square yards.
So it would be a massive place.
One hundred and five is the number of
captive orcas and Balugas and North
America.
So that includes marine land.
Some marine land has half the Balugas in
North America.
It's crazy.
And they fly under the radar because no
one wants to talk about them.
Right?
Twenty four slash seven round the clock
care care for the whales at the
sanctuary.
That sounds beautiful.
Murraylands threatened to sue these
people.
These people.
Somebody fucking.
I am dude,
but more.
We need more than just you.
It seems like.
Fuck man.
People listening.
Please get involved.
This is a great step though.
I love this idea of this step,
you know,
like have something that's like a bridge
between the captive and the wild.
Also it would allow their atrophied
dorsal fins to reinvigorate.
They could start diving deep again.
I mean you know how deep it necessarily,
but I mean at least a little bit and
get.
You could train these animals to
physically take them for walks,
if you will.
I guess you'd call him swims where you
will be able to leave and have them just
follow a boat and go for some exercise.
You can totally do.
I mean it really.
The things that this is going to
present,
the opportunities for these animals is
brilliant and amazing and the board is
comprised of all your,
all your wild animal brilliant
scientists.
I mean this is the project.
This is the future.
So that is the way to do it,
right?
Because I've always said when you go to
a place like sea world or whatever and
you look at all those dolphins and
killer whales,
like how would you get them free?
How did,
there would have to be some intermediary
step.
There it is.
Wow.
That's exciting times,
man.
I hope they do that man.
It's comp.
They do that because I feel like if
there was a place where you could go and
people could feed the killer whales like
released some fish or something like
that and be there to watch,
that would be way more exciting than
watching them in a swimming pool.
Watch a fucking killer whale fart in the
wild versus do a back flip in captivity
and you're watching that fight.
And uh,
and,
and this thing is just music and
bullshit.
I pulled over,
uh,
yesterday morning.
I was in Malibu real early in the
morning and uh,
I pulled over and watched some dolphins.
It was awesome.
I was told I was speaking with someone.
They're like,
dude,
they're here.
They're in Malibu.
Yeah,
they're here right now.
I was um,
I was on the pch and I was driving under
the corner of my eye,
saw something in the water and then I
saw the tail going over a few of them
together and I pulled over and I'm like,
fuck man,
that's amazing.
Like,
I don't want to live in mal books.
I'm scared of tsunamis.
But if you were there,
like right there,
like looking out your fucking bedroom
window and checking that out first thing
in the morning.
I wish dolphins in your yard.
Yeah.
And they're just wild man.
Having a good old time.
They just feel different,
you know,
you see them in marine land or I've
never seen him in marine land,
but you see him in any sort of captive
area and you just get this weird feeling
like,
yeah,
they're cool to look at.
But man,
they're just not.
They're just not,
you know,
there's something missing there.
It's like the difference between seeing
a cow in a pen versus a buffalo in the
wild,
you know,
just this is where hunters,
I say they're really.
This is where I get a lot of support
from hunters because didn't know
hunters.
I mean all you got to do is grab a
pigeon,
just go on the corner of street,
grab a pigeon,
if you can grab it,
put it in a cage and watch how depressed
you are in a half hour watching them.
I mean,
this is horrible.
So that's what I love about.
The hunters are just like,
no man,
you got this thing right?
Like fuck it.
Well,
and people have this erroneous idea that
hunters hate animals.
Kill Them.
They love wild animals.
They love things to be wild.
You know,
it's just a,
just a very depressing aspect of human
nature that we've chosen to go down this
route and that we did it a long time
ago.
I really truly believe that if there was
no dolphin and Orca captivity ever
previously before,
it would not be possible to do today.
Impossible.
People would freak out.
They would,
at least in America,
the future is brandon.
Uh,
kids are repulsed by it already.
I mean,
this is where they should be.
I go speak to schools and every kid in
the beautiful thing,
and I mean it sounds horrible,
but the kids that go to marina and get
singled out pretty bad by the other
kids,
so it's not a good time to bring your
kids to,
to,
to a place like marina and lets your
kids have your kids picked up.
What about China?
How is it?
How's it so cool in China?
They just don't get it over there.
They just don't know.
Fairly firm culture.
Yeah,
it's fairly new for sure.
Cultural.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't want.
I don't know.
I just know that that's,
that will be there for awhile yet.
Right?
The paradigm shift hasn't taken their
man.
That'll be a while.
Yeah.
So save smooshy.com
for anybody who wants to go and um,
and they can.
That's where your gofund me is,
that's where they can watch the
documentary.
And I'm listening,
man.
I hope in some way this helps.
You always does.
I'm super appreciative.
I hope in some way it gets people to
donate and to pay attention and to be
aware.
And please folks watched blackfish.
Just go watch that and if,
if it doesn't make you crack up,
if it doesn't make you cry,
it doesn't make you really sad that
people are capable of doing that.
It's just,
um,
it's just wrong.
It's just,
it's not,
it's not what we should be doing as a,
as a,
as a species,
as a race,
as a civilization.
It's just the wrong thing to do and one
day it will be looked upon very,
very poorly.
The timing of people putting their eyes
on me now,
it's never been better.
Things are gonna happen.
Follow me on twitter.
I'm going to be tweeting a lot of major
developments in the coming month.
The timing of this,
of this particular podcast couldn't have
been better.
And again,
I'm super indemnity forever.
I'm still appreciative.
I'm appreciative.
You too,
my brother.
Thanks man.
Thank you.
All right folks.
We'll be back next week.
Enjoy your life by.